hubo un camión de 1900 kilogramos tiene
una velocidad inicial de 12 metros sobre
segundo el conductor aplica los frenos y
el camión se detiene en 3.1 segundos
cuál es la mejor estimación de la
magnitud de la fuerza promedio de
frenado del camión pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo muy bien vamos a trabajarlo
juntos bueno probablemente la forma más
sencilla de resolverlo es calculando la
magnitud promedio de la aceleración del
camión que se detiene y después usar la
segunda ley de newton la fuerza es igual
a la masa por la aceleración ya que
conocemos la masa m del camión y con
esta masa y la aceleración podemos
calcular la magnitud promedio de la
fuerza de frenado que es lo que nos
piden que esté menos aquí podemos ver
que las opciones son muy diferentes así
que una estimación será suficiente
entonces primero pensemos en la
aceleración la aceleración es igual al
cambio de la velocidad con respecto al
tiempo
por lo tanto es igual a la velocidad
final menos la velocidad inicial
todo eso en el numerador en este caso
nuestra velocidad inicial es de 0 metros
por segundo porque se detiene menos la
velocidad inicial que era de 12 metros
por segundo y comúnmente se acostumbra
pensar que es el objeto se mueve hacia
la derecha el movimiento es positivo y
si se mueve hacia la izquierda es
negativo en este caso se mueve hacia la
derecha por lo tanto tenemos 12 metros
por segundo y es una velocidad positiva
así que restamos esa velocidad positiva
esto nos da el cambio de la velocidad
entre el cambio en el tiempo
en este caso el camión tardo 3.1
segundos y esto que sería
aproximadamente igual vamos a ver menos
12 entre 3.1 es aproximadamente igual a
menos 4 recuerden que solamente estamos
estimando el resultado puede ser más
cercano a menos 3.9 pero no pasa nada si
lo dejamos como aproximadamente igual
4 y las unidades son metros por segundo
al cuadrado y ahora usaremos la segunda
ley de newton para que con la ayuda de
esto podamos encontrar la magnitud de la
fuerza de frenado ahora es lógico que la
aceleración sea negativa porque la
velocidad va en esta dirección pero la
aceleración va en la dirección opuesta
ya que el camión está frenando con lo
que disminuye la velocidad entonces
nuestra fuerza neta se encuentra en la
misma dirección de la aceleración es
decir que va hacia la izquierda entonces
si tenemos este signo la fuerza será
negativa pero bueno aquí lo que nos
interesa es solo la magnitud para la
segunda ley de newton simplemente nos
fijamos en la magnitud de la aceleración
vamos a ver en la segunda ley de newton
la magnitud de la fuerza tiene que ser
igual a la masa
por la magnitud de la aceleración
entonces esto es aproximadamente igual a
la masa que son mil 900 kilogramos por 4
metros por segundo al cuadrado no sentir
la necesidad de escribir esto con signo
negativo porque solamente nos piden
obtener la magnitud así que solamente
nos interesa el valor absoluto por lo
tanto esto es aproximadamente igual a 4
por 1976 7.600 newtons ahora
si analizamos las opciones que nos dan
no veo 7.600 pero lo más cercano es
siete mil cuatrocientos y esta es una
buena respuesta porque aquí el valor
real debe de ser más cercano a menos 3.9
metros por segundo al cuadrado y si esto
fuera a 3.9 3.9 por 1900 es más cercano
a este valor así que esta es nuestra
respuesta correcta porque además las
otras opciones están muy lejos de
nuestra estimación
y eso es todo por este vídeo no te
preocupes nos vemos en el siguiente